avec nos pascal marcotte professeur à
l'université laval et chercheur à la
chaire de recherche en partenariat sur
l'attractivité et l'innovation en
tourisme et bonsoir madame marcotte
bonsoir c'était l'été qui hors norme
comme on n'a jamais vu finalement
comment on pourrait le qualifier d'après
vous à deux volets je pense d'une part
pour les régions qui ont reçu beaucoup
de visiteurs beaucoup de québécois
peut-être plus que qu'attendu et qui en
était d'ailleurs un fort heureux ces
régions et des villes notamment à québec
est encore plus montréal qui en ont eu
beaucoup moins et qu'ils ont je pense
été quand même peut-être heureux dans
les circonstances mais quand même déçu
et pour lesquelles les écarts sont très
grand avec les années précédentes le cas
de montréal et des autres grandes villes
d'ailleurs ailleurs au pays est atypique
en matière de tourisme pourquoi les
grandes villes justement ont souffert
davantage parce que les grandes villes
reçoivent davantage de clientèle
internationale
les frontières est enfermé évidemment
ces clientèles là ne pouvaient pas
occuper l'espace qu'ils occupent
d'habitude et les clientèles
internationales dépense beaucoup plus
donc de façon générale les québécois par
exemple vont visiter montréal mais ils
vont un petit peu moins ils étaient 2 à
1 pour une saison régulière ans entend
donc encore moins pour cette saison
aussi et quand ils vont ils consomment
un peu moins au restaurant ou un hôtel
ils vont davantage chez les parents chez
des amis et des en ce moment pour l'été
on avait davantage envie d'être dans la
nature d'être à l'extérieur et montréal
n'ayant pas ces grands festivals et son
offre culturelle n'étant peu ou pas
disponible mais évidemment les québécois
se sont tournés vers les régions pour
profiter un peu de la nature et du bon
temps et là vous dites montréal mais
j'aurais envie de dire toronto vancouver
calgary c'est à peu près la même chose
j'imagine oui toutes les grandes villes
qui ont davantage d après culturelles ou
des atrides de urbains ont été largement
marqué parce que si on pense par exemple
à la france
il semble que nice et marseille ce soit
bien débrouillé parce qu'elles ont un
imaginaire
tu vas alosi elles ont là-bas elles ont
tendu par et un beau coup sûr faire donc
c'est un peu partout pareil l'imaginaire
de l'été reste la mer la nature des
espaces un peu à l'extérieur
alors si les attraits culturels sont pas
présents c'est certain que les clients
ter sont aussi moins présent parlons de
québec par exemple c'est pas la
métropole mais on attire quand même
beaucoup de touristes étrangers à québec
bon c'est plus difficile en début de
saison touristique mais je pense que
finalement au bout de compte on a réussi
à tirer son épingle du jeu
oui et c'est principalement des régions
autour de québec qui ont réussi à
accueillir beaucoup de visiteurs donc
c'est une bonne nouvelle et il ya aussi
des histoires de québécois qui ont
profité de dunes achats donne à challans
d'âge moindre pour retrouver et
redécouvrir
finalement la ville ce qui fait qu'au
final c'est quand même positif
est-ce qu'il ya d'autres bonne nouvelle
malgré tout madame marcotte
mais si on regarde pas trop probablement
les fermetures importantes qui vont
arriver
on peut penser que cette redécouverte du
québec par les québécois peut être à
moyen terme une bonne nouvelle on va
probablement à vis de ce qu'on a
découvert quelque chose cette année
peut-être plutôt de force que degré tel
que les années prochaines on va avoir
envie d'y retourner et de profiter
davantage de l'offre touristique
québécoise dans le cortex économie où
les québécois dépensent de façon
générale beaucoup plus à l'extérieur
qu'au québec c'est peut-être l'occasion
d'investir un petit peu plus chez soi
aussi
et à quoi on peut s'attendre pour
l'automne parce qu'on vient d'apprendre
entre autres choses qu'ottawa garde les
mêmes restrictions là pour ce qui est
des voyageurs internationaux donc les
frontières ne voient pas s'ouvrir aux
étrangers ou en tout cas difficilement
ça va être pour les villes notamment
comme on disait c'est elle qui vont
écoper le plus parce que tant que cette
clientèle internationale n'y est pas un
c'est elle qui dépensent le plus ça va
faire mal
on pense entre autres à des clientèles
comme la les français ou les japonais
qui viennent voir les couleurs à
l'automne qui sont friands de ce produit
bas cette année ils n'y seront pas par
contre la clientèle québécoise
peut-être continuer à voyager un peu au
québec de façon générale elles voyagent
moins à l'automne à cause de la reprise
des activités scolaires et autres mais
il ya encore des belles possibilités
d'escapades déjà depuis les dernières
années et les québécois étaient allés
voir les couleurs eux aussi et sortait
en région donc ça sape est quand même
très positif par contre le tourisme
d'affaires on peut s'attendre à ce qu'il
soit encore anémique
parce que les entreprises préfèrent
investir dans des stades et des outils
de communication d'une part une
réorganisation du travail et c'est pas
le moment d'investir de prendre des
risques pour par exemple organiser des
fois vous des congrès sachant pas s'ils
vont pouvoir se tenir il y à des défis
pour l'industrie touristique quels sont
ils
ils sont nombreux et évidemment toute
l'incertitude on sait pas exactement
comment tout le monde veut réagir les
consommateurs les touristes même devront
acquérir de nouvelles habitudes c'est à
dire de planifier devoir venir
avant on avait une offre touristique
abonde donc on planifiait pas vraiment
idéal on ici mais il ya d'autres aussi
tendance de fond qui est elle auparavant
celle notamment de mélanger loisirs et
travail poilhes âge et travaille et on a
vu par exemple cet été les québécoises
acheté beaucoup de résidents secondaires
s'acheter présence hors des grands
centres
parce que le télétravail permet tait de
s'organiser comme ça et parce qu'on
avait peut-être envie de vivre davantage
dans la nature alors on peut se demander
dans les prochaines années
est-ce qu'on va les occuper un aux
résidents secondaires est ce qu'on va
avoir envie de retourner voyager si nous
on se pose la question on peut penser
que l'ensemble la planète n'a pas si ce
marché immobilier des résidents
secondaires on a tout acheté ça en même
temps est-ce que dans cinq ans quand on
va pouvoir recommencer à voyager est-ce
que ça va être un peu comme les 101
dalmatiens
on a vu tous les documents se jeta
dalmatiens et quelques mois plus tard on
sent des faisait qu'elle ait pas que ça
rassure les autres marchés aussi c'est
une question qu'on puisse poser parce
qu'évidemment nos activités économiques
sont extrêmement interreliés et
s'influencent cluny la presse que les
gens vont rapidement oublier la pandémie
après un vaccin ou un traitement aussi
on va être peut-être un peu plus plus
pour reprendre les habitudes de voyage
de pascal marcotte merci beaucoup je
vous en prie au revoir au revoir